it's monday the 22nd of november
christmas parade horror at least five
people are dead more than 40 injured as
an suv drives at high speeds into crowds
including children
we're under the window and it was just
absolute chaos people screaming
please reveal they fired at the suspect
to try to stop the vehicle they're now
in custody we'll have the latest
throughout the programme
sky news visits is bride shamima begum
in a prison camp she tells us she wants
a chance to face a uk court
what about the accusations that have
been leveled at you
about
your activity with islamic state they're
all completely false and have no basis
to them and i'm willing to fight them in
a court of law but i'm not being given
the chance
covert tensions across europe with fresh
protests in belgium as austria returns
to full lockdown
tory mps urged to rebel on social care
proposals amid anger that the least
well-off may be left worse off
south end prepares to pay its respects
to the late sir david amos in a
constituency memorial as the prime
minister pays tribute
he showed what you can achieve as an mp
to change the lives of people up and
down the country and
he will be much much missed
i'm here at old trafford where the
search is underway for a new manager and
as the rumor mill goes into overdrive it
seems that uh real madrid legend
zinedine zidane is not interested in
coming to manchester
[Music]
good morning we begin with a breaking
news from overnight an attack on a
christmas parade in wisconsin at least
five people have been killed and 40
injured after an suv drove at high speed
into crowds of people in the street
including dancing children police have
revealed they fired at the vehicle to
try to stop it they have a suspect in
custody our u.s correspondent martha
kelner reports
[Music]
for some in waukesha it was a near miss
a brush with death this young girl
dressed in pink is safe but only by
inches
many were not so fortunate
this is the moment families watching the
christmas parade realize something is
horrifically wrong a red suv speeds past
a marching band off camera it plows
indiscriminately into other performers
mowing them down from behind
school children and dancing granny stood
no chance police say there are
fatalities and many parade goers were
injured
it was just absolute chaos people
screaming and i immediately ran
downstairs outside of my apartment
and i could see kids
just
laying on the street people putting
blankets over them trying to attend to
them kids screaming on the sidewalks and
not really knowing what happened
the car had cleared a police cordon
officers shot at the driver attempting
to stop the carnage
we experienced a horrible senseless
tragedy
i walked in the parade at the beginning
i saw the happy children sitting on the
curb i saw the happy parents behind
their children
i can still see the smiling faces
a parade is a celebration for our
community
today our community faced horror and
tragedy in what should have been a
community celebration
we're no longer looking for a suspect
vehicle
we do have a personal interest in
custody at the moment
but this is still a very fluid
investigation
as president at this tragic event and
saw firsthand the resiliency
of the community coming together
schools across walkershore are closed
today this city of 75 000 is coming to
terms with the death and destruction
visited upon it questions now turn to
who this is at the wheel and why they
turned a joyous celebration into a
nightmare martha kellner sky news
coming up in just a moment or two we'll
be speaking to the government minister
joining us this morning want to ask him
in mr scully of course obviously a
regular on the program want to ask him
amongst other things about shimaima
begum she's told sky news that she fears
for her safety and wants to face a court
in the uk challenging officials to visit
and question her inside syria if they
still believe she's a threat she was
just 15 years old when she traveled to
syria she claims it was after months of
grooming when she was at a vulnerable
point in her life she's now 22 and she's
been speaking exclusively to our middle
east correspondent alistair
feel like the only crime i committed was
coming here so i would be willing to
go to prison for that but like for the
accusations made against me i'm just
gonna have to fight against them
and see what happens whether i win or
lose i will just have to sit
a sentence at some point in my life i
don't think i can reassure them i think
only the government can reassure them
and the only way for the government to
reassure them is if they come
to see me or if they take me back
and you know interrogate me
however long they want to interrogate me
you know they have people for this to
like detect liars
from the truth tellers you know it's
not hard to see who's lying and who's
not lying and who's consistent and he's
not consistent
as i said uh paul scully is with us
should she have the opportunity to face
the british court i think the supreme
court has ruled on the uh on on this
matter what i don't want to do i mean
it'd be interesting to see uh the extent
of the interview but uh
in terms of the actual case what i don't
want to do is have it out
via broadcast it needs to be heard it
has been heard at the supreme court
after the home secretary made a really
clear ruling yeah one wonders i mean she
says that she was groomed she said she's
22 now um
and she's sorry but she wants to face
justice in a british court
i think it's reasonable to say before
seeing all of the interview that people
should be allowed to repent shouldn't
they yeah i think what is the reason
that i say that um the decisions
shouldn't be taken although the interest
the interview is interesting uh the
decisions shouldn't be taken out in
public because the home secretary took
his decision with intelligence documents
with other documents that i haven't seen
uh that we haven't seen so in order to
take that complete um uh decision it's
really important that they have both
sides of the story which they've had as
i say in making the decision and at the
supreme court which validated the
decision of the home sector at the time
it would be humane to i mean she's she's
stateless at the moment
don't we have a responsibility to um at
least give her the opportunity to have
her case heard in the uk well i think as
i say the the case itself has been heard
i think she's uh she's obviously has a h
g is getting her voice across through
through your program here and through
other channels as well i've seen
a number of um reports in in uh print
journalism as well uh so so that is
coming across but nonetheless this these
are really pivotal decisions rightly so
because it's about national security
it's about um uh actors the in the
traveling to other countries to do
damage against british interests well as
we were discussing there with the
minister shamima begum has told sky news
she was promised paradise when she
joined islamic state and it turned out
to be in her words hell she was talking
exclusively to our middle east
correspondent alastair bunkel who joins
us now from syria hello to alastair um
you spent quite a lot of time with her
judging from what the minister was
saying unlikely that she's going to find
herself back on british soil any time
soon
no the decision to stripper of her
british citizenship was taken by the
former home secretary sajid javid uh it
has been upheld if you like uh nominally
at least by the current home secretary
of pretty patel and there is no
suggestion under the uh current
conservative government that they will
reverse that decision at least not
willingly
maybe they will have to if the
bagan family and their lawyers had a
successful
court outcome but the supreme court has
been challenged uh on that decision and
they also upheld sajid javid's position
on it so shamima began as it stands at
the moment is not a british citizen uh
the british government say that she has
dual bangladeshi heritage
but she has never visited bangladesh
itself and the bangladeshi government
say nothing to do with us and so
therefore you've got a situation where
she's in a prison a prison camp uh in
kurdish controlled northern syria and
the kurds who guard her and other
foreign fighters are saying look you
know we've got to do something about it
because we simply don't have the space
we don't have the money and we don't
have the capability to hold these former
isis brides and isis fighters
indefinitely so at some point it will
come to a crunch but yeah we spent uh
quite a long time with her actually and
i think it probably is one of the more
informal interviews that she's done we
wandered around the camp she introduced
me to her friends and showed me uh where
she lived at the moment and i asked her
what happened back in 2015 when as a 15
year old she left east london with two
other school friends and how it was that
they became to find themselves on that
journey to syria
i just slowly started becoming
practicing you know and i it opened this
a doorway to like new people and a new
life that i thought i wanted and i
thought i
could fit into you know and i i didn't
fit into my community or my family so i
felt like i was going somewhere where i
could you know be accepted more for who
i was i didn't hate britain i just hated
my life in britain why because i felt
very constricted and i felt like i
couldn't live the life that i wanted in
the uk of a british woman i just wanted
freedom of choice in a way to make my
own decisions not have to like
ask my parents permission first or think
about my community's
you know view of what i'm doing i just
wanted to do what i wanted you know
the case of shamima begum completely
divides british opinion there'll be
those who've watched what she's just had
to say there and think uh she's got
everything that's come to her goodreads
she should never be allowed back in the
united kingdom and all those that
probably agree what shamima begum has to
say and feel that she at the very least
should be allowed to come back to the uk
as you know i should point out uh other
people in her situation have done both
british and european and she should be
allowed to face a course of law and have
her day
in court put her side of the story
across have that challenged uh by the uk
establishment um but as i said she is
where she is at the moment and i think
uh she probably uh in her quieter
moments albeit not admitting on camera
recognizes that her options are running
out and perhaps the time is running out
to return to the uk okay uh alastair
thanks very much indeed and if you want
to see an extended version of alastair's
report you can do that online and on our
social media um
uh we of course will be speaking to him
again in the next hour meantime uh
looking uh quickly at these uh the
morning's papers for you the eye reports
ministers are pushing for coveted
boosters to be offered to all over 18s
in a bid to hold the virus from
spreading the express has the same story
saying covered booster japs will save
christmas
the telegraph leads with violence
erupting after a new wave of coronavirus
cases spread at lightning speed in
europe
the guardian leads on growing concerns
of a government backbench rebellion over
controversial plans to scale back the
cap on social care
let's take you to austria now which woke
up this morning in national lockdown
and this is the scene in vienna this
morning deserted given people can leave
their homes for a limited number of
reasons such as going to work or buying
essential food
that's in stark contrast to these scenes
just 24 hours ago where people
desperately tried to squeeze in a last
minute trip to the city's christmas
market before it closed for business
and these are some of the most recent
shots from brussels where riot police
used water cannon on those who came out
to protest over the weekend
joining us now is the shadow health
secretary uh labour's jonathan ash with
hello to you mr asher thanks for joining
us we've seen what's happening across
europe how concerned are you about what
might happen in the uk
well i definitely don't want to see
another of one of boris johnson's
lockdowns imposed upon us especially not
over christmas
the way to avoid that is to
fix the vaccination campaign it has
stalled i mean we are expanding access
to boosters that's a good thing but if
you're in the immunocompromised
community i i you've got a serious
long-term health condition it's been
pretty chaotic as to whether you get a
third job or not so that's what the
charities have said there's still parts
of the country where the second job rate
like leicester or blackburn uh still
isn't good enough we need to really
drive that up but of course you've got
to put in place other protections as
well we still don't pay people decent
sick pay we're still not uh doing enough
to deal with the fact that the virus is
airborne we're still breathing in
contaminated air we're not putting in
place air filtration systems in public
buildings to improve the quality of air
so the ball is in the minister's court
really they've got to put these
protections in place to avoid further
restrictions but i definitely do not
want another one of boris johnson's
lockdowns they do a huge amount of
damage to family life to community lives
to the
the economy um so it's really it's
really worrying when you see what's
happening in austria and parts of europe
credit where it's due though they've
been doing very well with the rollout
when it comes after a shaky start when
it comes to the booster
the booster is beginning to pick up but
that the booster is now one only one
element of that vaccination program
we've got children's vaccinations which
are for adolescents which are still
far too low as i say you've got the
third jobs for the people with uh
conditions such as
blood cancers and other serious
conditions where it's been chaotic
frankly there's that's as i say the
charities are making those complaints uh
and there's still parts of the country
um like leicester like calderdale like
burnley they're like bolton where the
second dose rates are not as high as
they should be and the reason i mention
those particular places is they're the
areas that boris johnson put into local
lockdowns and the government seems to
have given up on their second dose rates
that's simply not good enough those
areas need more support to really drive
up their second dose rates as well
voting on social care later on in the
house of commons we were speaking to the
minister just a few moments ago i'm sure
you caught what he was having to say
basically um what the government is
introducing is much better than what's
in place at the moment
well remember the government have
imposed a punishing tax rise on working
people across the country to fund this
plan and when you look at the details of
it it's not a care plan it's a care con
because
if you live in a one million pound house
perhaps in the home counties uh 90 of
your assets will be protected if you
need social care but if you live in a
sort of 80 000 pound terrace house in in
hartlepool or barrow mansfield
or wigan for example you lose nearly
everything that is not fair that's not
leveling up it's daylight robbery so
we're saying to tory mps join with us
tonight in rejecting this proposal and
instead ask the minister to retreat to
the drawing board and come up with
something fairer
this is a scheme this scheme is better
though than what's in place at the
moment and even andrew dill not uh
agrees with that
but remember everybody is also being
asked to pay more tax and if you're in
hartlepool or mansfield bury where i'm
originally from
wigan or salford where i was born or
even leicester where i now live you're
being asked to pay more tax to fund a
system which benefits wealthier
homeowners and you will potentially will
still lose out you'll still lose
thousands and thousands of pounds even
though you're paying more tax that's why
it's an unfair system it's why tory mps
privately have branded an inheritance
tax across the north so let's reject it
take it off the table and come up with a
fairer alternative
haven't those wealthier people paid more
tax during the course of their working
life
but at the moment
working people are going to be paying
more in national insurance as well as
their council tax going up as well as
their income tax going up because the
personal allowance is being frozen
because richie sudan is one of the
biggest tax rising chancellors uh in of
recent years so ordinary people it's
really it's a real struggle at the
moment we've also got inflation going up
so the cost of living the cost of things
in the shops is going up as well so yeah
you're really clobbering uh working
people at the moment are really
struggling their wage packet is being
stretched further and further and
further you're asking them now to fund a
system which benefits people with a
million pound houses it's not fair as i
say it's not leveling up it's daylight
robbery let's reject it and let's work
on a fairer alternative
and yet still uh boris johnson and the
uh government seem to um have i know
they're a little bit behind in the polls
at the moment but come the um next
election what what's going to happen how
are you going to get those red wall
seats back
well uh and the next general election
we've got to work hard to convince
people to uh put their trust in labor
because i think kirsten will be a much
better prime minister of this country
than boris johnson and i think we need a
a labour government but look you're
absolutely right lots of people across
the north and the midlands voted tori
for the first time they put their trust
in boris johnson in places like uh
radcliffe and berry where i'm from uh
and part and across the wigan area uh
where you're from um but boris johnson
is squandering that trust he's betraying
that trust because he's gone back on his
promises he made about rail last week
he refused to he he's got all this sort
of corruption and he tried to sort of
bail his mates out on it and now he's
imposing a tax rise on everybody in
order to fund a care system which only
bet which hugely benefits the very
wealthy and the rich that's not fair so
i think boris johnson is squandering the
trust but we've got to build trust in
ourselves and we'll do that by talking
about the good jobs we'll deliver the
better wages we'll deliver the improved
health service we'll build the better
schools we'll build will deliver for
people in uh across the whole of the
country and how we'll make our streets
safer by investing in our police force
as well
okay let's talk about um the home
secretary her colleagues her civil
servants coming out and briefing against
her in the weekend papers whatever you
think of the home secretary that is
totally inappropriate behavior
well i always think you get briefing and
sniping anonymous sniping and briefing
all the time in politics and it's not
nice it shouldn't you know it it
shouldn't happen it's destabilizing
my issue with pretty patel isn't whether
anonymous civil servants may or may not
be saying in the newspapers is that
pretty patel is failing on the things
that she promised to deliver i mean
you know she's failed she's failed to
deliver the the extra resources to keep
our communities safer and the way in
which uh we need here in an area uh like
leicester she's failing to get a grip of
the problems and with the the
immigration system she's a very poor
home secretary actually and that's my
issue with pretty patel
okay good to talk to you as always come
and see us in the studio soon thank you
thanks a lot
looking at the latest covered figures
just talking about them there weren't we
40 000 and
four new cases of covid in the last 24
hours the government says a further 61
people had died within 28 days of
testing positive for covid19 bringing
the uk total my goodness me to almost
144
143
927 people have succumbed
to covet these are the latest vaccine
figures
almost
25 000
first doses received
that first dose of the vaccine the
second dose is there at 23
381 however you can see the total second
dose is 46 million
150 000 thereabouts um and when it comes
to the boosters i can tell you 15
million
boosters have now been given out in the
administered in the uk 400 000 more than
400 000 yesterday joining us now is
david nabarro the special envoy on covet
19 the world health organization it's
always great to see you thank you for
joining us how concerned are you about
the images that we're seeing in belgium
and the netherlands and italy and
croatia people saying enough don't lock
us down anymore
i can understand people saying enough
kay
this virus just goes on and on doesn't
it
i mean of course i'm really
very very anxious about what i'm seeing
right across europe including now in
western europe these very large numbers
of cases but it's also the speed with
which they're increasing
really is a cause for concern i'm not
surprised because this virus is just not
going away and i'm also not surprised
that people are protesting because
actually the public in so many countries
are really fed up with what's going on
however me as a public health person
i've got to share with you kay and with
your viewers
that we we're going to have to go on
we're going to have to go on resisting
this virus and and we do it through
making it hard for the virus to get from
one person to another with face masks
and also with avoiding breathing in the
air breathed out by others and by the
way the face masks have got to be well
fitting you know if we keep that
personal protection going especially in
confined spaces evidence is really
strong that this reduces the size of the
surges and the peaks and and then the
second thing of course is to actually
get make sure that those who are
eligible for vaccination are vaccinated
and vaccinated promptly because that
also makes a huge difference to the
amount of suffering and death so we've
got to keep going and please everybody
take it really seriously this virus has
got so many surprises in store for us
mandatory vaccines good idea
sorry i missed that
mandatory vaccines yeah are they a good
idea
oh i'm glad i asked you to repeat it
gave me a chance to think about it you
know i i'm one of these people who
always hopes that it's possible to
approach a problem like this through
partnership between people and different
authorities local authorities national
authorities even global authorities
after all we're in this together and
people are the only solution that the
world has to dealing with this virus
there's no magic magic bullet or
whatever you might call it that's going
to come along and help
its people and and people uh working
together so if it's at all possible to
avoid having to require people to be
vaccinated otherwise they get some kind
of penalty
i'd really prefer that if on the other
hand there's absolute refusal then i
quite understand governments uh looking
at the possibility of mandating uh like
many things i would see this as a last
resort
how do you feel about travel
at the moment um actually traveling
between the uk and europe has become
easier and easier i know that you've
managed to um see your grandchildren of
late um should that be tightened up
again
well i'm not going to suggest that there
needs to be a lot of effort tightening
up travel i think that what we need to
do is to try to make it possible for
people to move around safely and there's
some really good work underway on that
with the airlines at airports and so on
but at the same time i think that every
individual does need to try to reduce
the likelihood that they're going to get
infected with this virus
so always when you're making a journey
first of all look and see if you can get
the information how much virus there is
being transmitted in the place you're
going to and also check that you're not
going to be taking it inadvertently to
another place that's not got it and
secondly ask yourself is this really
essential because especially if there's
a high risk with the travel if there's a
lot more virus where you're going to
it's just it just would be so unwise if
if you then got sick and got ill and
then perhaps got serious problems when
you didn't really need to do the journey
so my role for myself is
essential travel only and that can mean
essential for emotional well-being as
essential for economic or educational
purposes
where are you as far as long covid is
concerned um
my old buddy piers morgan um it's ages
since he got covered and he says he
still
is still poorly still doesn't have
enough energy he still can't smell um
anything um how seriously should we take
long covered
well you see i take everything about
this virus seriously i think it's just a
beastly thing and it's always surprising
us let's just describe long covered for
a bit
about one in 20 people who get covered
may get
long symptoms means they don't just
recover back to normal immediately after
they've had the illness
and those of you who know someone with
long covert like you know piers morgan
uh that you know that the person really
feels that they're walking around with
their head in a blanket
basically the brain and the arms and the
legs they're not communicating properly
you feel fuzzy headed you get really
tired and perhaps most importantly it
kind of it gets better then it doesn't
it it gets worse again then it gets
better again then it gets worse again to
those of you who are watching who got
long covered just i want to say to you i
at least and my colleagues realized that
this is a very serious problem
i mean that's also why we're asking
everybody don't treat kovid lightly
don't just assume if you're young you
get it and then you're fine be careful
about these covet parties where people
being brought together to get the
illness in order to try to perhaps
reduce the challenges they face
subsequently not everybody who gets this
illness actually recovers and as i said
1 in 20 have a long illness and it takes
many months to go away
quick thought about otter before i let
you go
well my grandson otto is now a bit over
a year old like many children in the uk
he's in this situation where actually
there's a lot of covert moving around in
the in the schools in the nurseries and
and it's quite challenging for the
parents because they really do not want
to bring kobe into the home and they
certainly don't want covid going into
their workplaces i just think every time
i i
engage with my beautiful grandson i'm
thinking this is a tough time for
parents
especially given the amount of covet
moving around in schools and i'm going
to just continue to say to everybody i
think it's right to continue to treat
this virus as though it's a nasty thing
i think it's right to be having your
face mask ready and to put it on
whenever you go into any kind of crowded
space i think it's right for kids in
schools uh to be wearing masks if they
if they perceive that that's desirable
and the parents and school teachers want
them to
i think it's right for us to be
practicing this physical distancing not
lockdowns not working from home but just
respecting the fact that we can reduce
transmission by maintaining distance i
think that's what we've got to do for
the foreseeable future
everybody always great to talk to you
yeah absolutely it's always great to
talk to you thank you very much for
joining us thank you okay bye bye
bye-bye
in other news the confederation of
british industry meets today in the port
of tine in the northeast top of its
agenda leveling up joined now by the
organization's director general tony
danke hello to mr danker thank you for
joining us at leveling up uh where are
we on leveling up given what we've just
been told about hs2
well where we are actually this morning
you're right is at the port of time it's
very fresh but the cbi is trying its own
leveling up we've got conference going
on in eight different locations around
the country and hoping to hear shortly
from the prime minister and you're right
leveling up to date has been a very
political conversation i think it's time
we talked about economics because what
people in this part of the world want is
they want better jobs better wages and
high growth businesses all over the
place that's why businesses are involved
in leveling up and it's why the prime
minister myself will be talking about it
this morning
how do you rate the government's
attempts at leveling up so far
well look i think there's been uh the
prime minister's been absolutely right
to put it front and center of the agenda
so i give him a lot of credit for that
you know the truth is for five decades
okay no one's really wanted to talk
about it it seemed like there's this
inexorable shift of everything
southwards to the southeast and of
course now with things like
decarbonization and with cyber security
and life sciences these are new
industries that don't have to be based
in london they can be based around the
country so i think full marks for
putting it first there's been a lot of
talk about the politics today there's
been lots of talk about mayors and how
our high streets look and so on what the
government hasn't got on to yet is
really look how do we get people better
jobs how do we get better skills how do
we make places like this as much of a
hub of economic activity is the south
now that isn't easy for government to do
they can't do it alone but we've really
heard very little from the prime
minister and the government yet on how
to do that and that's what i hope we'll
talk about today
yeah um but i bring you back to hs2 and
the fact that one way to enter into
connect the country very small country
is to have a better rail service
yeah look you're absolutely right and
let's not sugarcoat this right
businesses in this part of the world uh
we're disappointed with the news on rail
they've been upset by it
and i think what they're hoping for is
that the prime minister the government
the transport secretary will get into a
second round of conversations on it and
interestingly it's been less about
connectivity to the south and much more
as you imply about connectivity across
the north about all the cities in the
north of england being connected to each
other and connected to economic activity
so i hope we haven't heard the last of
it i hope the government will keep on
talking
where does the cbi stand on halving the
air passenger duty
domestic
well well look i think uh it's clear
that the government
went about that measure not for the
reasons people think but they're trying
to better connect different airports
around the country to heathrow if you
live in a part of the uk that isn't next
to a major airport like heathrow
it's incredibly inconvenient to have to
travel overseas on holiday our travel
overseas for business so i think that
was the government's main motivation but
i think we can be in no doubt that
actually on all forms of transport what
we need is a massive green revolution
and i hope alongside their measures
taken so far by the government they'll
push harder on sustainable aviation fuel
to make even aviation uh as green as it
can be because we do need a green
transport revolution
does that mean that you d as an
organization you do support the halving
of the domestic care passenger duty or
not
well i think we supported any incentives
to improve connectivity but i don't
think that in the long run what we can
be doing is having duties uh or having
taxes that don't incentivize green
behavior so i i know exactly why the
government did it this time around and
so uh you know i i welcome the fact that
they're trying to better connect
regional airports let's see if that
measure works if it doesn't work then we
should look at other ways to support
regional airports so let's wait and see
if it has the impact it hopes for but i
think doing it without working on
sustainable aviation fuel which is the
real prize to decarbonize uh aviation
and air transport that as a measure in
and of itself i don't think it will do
enough good to talk to you busy day
ahead for you we must let you go thank
you very much indeed
thanks a lot thanks a lot
just want to update you further on the
breaking news that we had for you in
wisconsin from overnight were several
people who were taking part in a
christmas parade had been caught up
in a tragedy there when a vehicle plowed
into
several of the people taking part in
that
parade police have said a person of
interest who may have a significant
criminal history was being questioned
overnight
nbc reporting that the investigators are
looking at the possibility that the
driver had been involved in an earlier
incident involving a knife and was
fleeing the scene when the vehicle
reached the parade just after 4 30 pm
local time an fbi spokesperson saying
that the bureau was aware of the event
but that
local authorities will lead the enquiry
dozens of people have been injured as a
direct result of that incident at 4 30
local time several people are also known
to have died youngsters
and the elderly
older people i should say alike
taking part in that parade when a
vehicle plowed into them police did
shoot out the vehicle to try to stop it
they were unsuccessful in that regard
several people caught up under the
wheels of that vehicle and that vehicle
has now been discovered and
a person of interest has been arrested
the government will bring its social
care proposals before mps today but
there's the threat of a rebellion by
tories mps are concerned that with a cap
of 86 000 pounds on social care costs
some people will still be forced to sell
their homes to pay for social care
something the prime minister said before
the election would not happen but small
business minister paul scully told me
the prime minister was not lying when he
said that
what we're now in the position to do is
to uh to say there is the cap there is
the the uh above which you will not have
to pay for social care which is a fair
and balanced approach he was telling
lies then in order to win the election
no no i don't think it was
what he did he promised he was boiling
he was boiling down a complicated
message um which is why as i say social
care hasn't been dealt with in in at
least 10 years
tamara's here so if he wasn't lying what
was he doing well that's the question
kay and i was talking to some quite
senior conservatives last night former
ministers former cabinet ministers and
the word over-promising came up quite a
bit that by saying he wanted to fix
social care
in the injustice of people selling their
homes boris johnson raised expectations
about what is a very very complicated
area
what the government want to do we
learned a few months ago is introduce a
cap of 86 000 pounds so currently people
who have the misfortune to spend many
years in residential care can
potentially
have a bottomless pit of costs that will
be capped at 86 000 pounds it turns out
now that the burden of that will fall on
people with the fewest assets they won't
be able to use any of the state help
they get towards that cap and therefore
it highlights some existing problems
with this which is that it's the same
cap for everybody regardless of how
expensive their house is and there's a
lot of tories feeling that after the
debacle about sleaze and after the
problems with the train announcement
last week they don't want this one to
also blow up in their faces and they're
asking the government for urgent
reassurance about it samara's take at
nine o'clock looking forward to it thank
you very much
meantime a constituency memorial for the
mps to david amis will take place later
on today the private service is being
held in south end this afternoon sir
david died after being stabbed while
holding a constituency surgery at leon c
in october his funeral will take place
at westminster cathedral tomorrow the
prime minister has spoken of his
admiration of the late mp
he was a guy who
campaigned about things he really cared
for whether it was animal welfare
people who suffered from endometriosis
which he brought to widespread public
attention or campaigning against fuel
poverty uh he showed what you can
achieve as an mp uh to change the lives
of people up and down the country and
he will be much much missed
and we will be uh speaking to the vicar
who's carrying out that service later on
meantime questions still being asked
about the well-being of chinese tennis
player pang shui she's now had a
30-minute call with the president of the
international olympic committee so is
that enough asia correspondent tom
cheshire with us in beijing still some
concerns though tom
yeah i think those concerns haven't
really been dispelled by the call it was
a bizarre weekend here in beijing after
not hearing of uh anything about
pongshui since she made those
allegations that she was forced into sex
by a very senior communist party
official uh chinese state media put out
videos of her visiting a restaurant and
then
on sunday morning of her taking part in
a tennis tournament at the opening
ceremony and then later in the day the
international olympic committee put out
a statement saying they had spoken to
pong and that she was safe and well they
she told them living in a home in
beijing but would like to have her
privacy respected at this time no
mention there of those allegations of
sexual abuse and that's what has got the
wta the women's tennis association uh
concerned about this they've been
pushing for an investigation into those
allegations ever since she first made
them and have been pretty unflinching in
their support for her they said that
this did not alleviate or address the
wa's concerns they want a full fair and
transparent investigation without
censorship into her allegation of sexual
assault and i think the wta isn't going
to be convinced until they've been able
to at least speak to pengshui herself
and that's not what has happened yet
she's only spoken to the ioc according
to their statement
okay for now thank you
manchester united today beginning a
global search for a new manager
following the sacking of early gonna
solve sky uh yesterday joined now by our
north of england correspondent fraser
moore who is at old trafford hello to um
fraser i thought he was very charming in
his uh goodbye speech
was very gracious wasn't it uh as he
left the club many fans thinking that uh
it was not a moment too soon in fact
he's been here for just less than three
years the longest manager in managerial
terms since uh sir alex ferguson left
and i think fans as much as they love
him as a player love him as a club icon
a lot of them are happy to see him go
and they now want a marquee manager to
come and take his place zinedine zidane
formerly of real madrid he left there
back in may he's currently on a
sabbatical uh there's been rumors that
he might be approached but we're hearing
today from sources close to zinedine
zidane that he is not interested in
coming here to manchester there are
rumors about him potentially going to
psg when he's finished this sabbatical
that's where maurizio pochettino is at
the moment there are rumors that
pochettino is on manchester's wanted
list as well and we're also hearing
reports today that the leicester manager
brendan rodgers has also been approached
by manchester united it would cost an 8
million pounds to buy him out of his
contract at leicester he was asked by a
reporter a couple of weeks ago whether
he would be interested in the manchester
job and he said that that reporter was
disrespectful for even considering to
ask such a question but we're hearing on
the rumor mill today that he has now
been approached by manchester united
there are others uh on the wish list as
well or on the speculative list list as
well eric tanharg at iax he's uh he's um
favored by many manchester united fouls
ralph rangeric uh who's currently at
locomotive moscow former schalke foreign
there's talk that he might be able to
come here as an interim but he says he's
potentially not interested in coming
here as an interim lauren blanc louis
enrique ronald kerman all names that are
in the hat for the next job here one of
the biggest jobs in football and a tough
one to say the very least